Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge Das Podcast UFO, heute mit Stefan Tietze und Florentin Will. 80% des Erfolgs eines Podcasts hängen davon ab, einfach durchzuhalten und irgendwie einigermaßen technische Probleme zu überwenden. Ja, dass die Technik auch mitspielt, einfach so. Wir hatten schon so oft, dass irgendwie Kopfhörer kaputt gegangen sind. Aber ich sag's, wie ich oft sag, kaufste billig, kaufste zweimal. Kaufste billig, kaufste zweimal. Ja, kann man auch sagen, schön die Kopfhörer und dann irgendwie für 6,99 bei Lidl, wir brauchen neue Kopfhörer und dann kaufste und kaufste und kaufste. Wann glaubst du, ist so das Podcast-Equipment im Lidl angekommen? Einfach so schön, das ist also ein Mikro, wenn es kaputt ist, kannst du ein neues holen wie so ein Rasierer, den du nachkaufst. So Max Nachtsheim präsentiert und dann hast du so ein ganzes Set mit so einem Interface-Mikrofon. Und so ein Rockstar-Aufsteller, wie er dann so die Arme ausbreitet, den du auch mitnehmen kannst dann. Ja, das finde ich gut. Da liegt auch so ein Zettel mit so ein paar Gags, irgendwie so die Podcast-Bibel, ICE-Stories. Früher, weißt du noch, als im Kindergarten wir geprickelt haben und dann schön hast du tausend Likes. Da habe ich einmal einen Witz gemacht,
der ein bisschen wie an die neuen Nineties Kids gerichtet war
und ich kriege seit Wochen Sprüche dafür,
Ballert von Florian.
Du hast dich einfach verkauft, du hast deine Seele verkauft.
Nein, das ist lustig, ich fand das lustig, dass man prickelt im Kindergarten,
aber es nie wieder braucht.
Und irgendwann, warum gibt es die Scheren?
Es gibt auch so Scheren, die, ist es nicht so,
dass sich Kindergartenkinder sofort anfallen?
Das war diese Angst, man gibt denen keine richtigen Messer, man gibt denen keine richtigen Scheren. Was glauben die, was Kindergartenkinder da machen? Dass Kindergartenkinder dann sofort aufeinander einstechen, auf die Scheißlea mit dem Kack grinsen und ihren Scheißzöpfen, sofort einfach in die Fresse, die ... Nein, natürlich nicht. Aber gab es nicht auch so Scheren, die in so Mustern geschnitten haben, wo dann so lauter kleine Piraten waren und was abgeschnitten haben. Oh mein Gott, danke.
Das ist wirklich, es nimmt ja jegliche Kreativität weg, weil du kannst ja nicht mal, du kannst nur diese eine Form schneiden, dann schenkt man das seiner Mutter und dann sagt sie, wow, das ist aber schön gemacht. Nein, die Schere ist einfach gut. Wer hat mein Diplom zerschnitten? Man muss ja dazu sagen, für viele, die es vielleicht nicht so ganz mitbekommen haben, Stefan macht gerade eine ganz merkwürdige Phase durch. Ich weiß nicht, warum du das beobachtest. Wir sind in der neuen Phase des Stephans angekommen. Es ist so, er hatte seine Frauenphase, er hatte seine Bandphase, er hatte seine, ich will erfolgreicher. Mucki-Phase! Mucki-Phase hatten wir und jetzt kommt die ganz krasse Regressionsphase. Stefan wird wieder zum Kind. Er redet die ganze Zeit nur über Kleinkinderkram, über Kindergarten, er hat sich einen Rubik's Cube gekauft und puzzelt damit jetzt die ganze Zeit rum. Heute komme ich rein ins Büro, denk mir nichts dabei und sehe, Stefan Tietze sitzt da mit seinem Rubik's Cube in der Hand und isst Cornflakes mit Milch aus einer Schüssel. Etwas, das es bei uns in der Redaktion noch nie gab. Dass jemand sich morgens Cornflakes und Milch gekauft hat und dann naschend da saß und erliest die Rückseite der Packung. Wo ich mir dachte einfach, was ist da los, Stefan? du bist wieder acht Jahre alt. Und die Micky mir ausgekauft, natürlich, das hast du vergessen.
Das Ding ist, glaube ich, unterbewusst, ist mir gar nicht aufgefallen, dass ich, der Rubik's Cube, ist da was für, also mich beruhigt das, ist der moderne, ist der Back to the Roots Fidget Cube, der, wo man rumfummeln kann in Meetings.
Ah, der ist so hipsterig vielleicht.
Ja, natürlich ist das hipsterig, wenn der mal wieder anfängt, über ihren Bullshit zu reden.
Weißt du, es geht auch nicht um spannende Themen bei uns in der Sitzung, um coole Videos und Sketche, sondern es geht auch um Sticker. Und dann was soll auf die Sticker drauf? Und dann nehme ich meine Rubikskübe raus und fange an, ein bisschen rumzudrehen damit. Das ist halt auch manchmal so ein bisschen Ablenkung, um mein Gehirn, was ständig nach Impulsen sucht, ein bisschen zu stimulieren. Und dann, gut, Clownflex, dann hast du halt mir diese ganzen Sachen aufgezählt jetzt gerade und ich merke, ja, das stimmt schon. Unterbewusst vielleicht findet so eine leichte Phase des Rückschritts statt. Und es ist vielleicht auch einfach deswegen, weil man jetzt im erwachsenen Berufsleben angekommen ist. Man sehnt sich vielleicht einfach an die ruhigere Zeit. Ich glaube, du bist einfach ganz verzweifelt auf der Suche noch einem USP. Du willst einfach der, der immer den Rubik's Cube hat, der, der immer irgendwie Cornflakes ist. Du willst einfach einen USP haben und vielleicht ist das ja auch der neue Trend irgendwie so. Man hat ja jetzt irgendwie gerade die Retro-Phase, wo viele Leute dann irgendwie nochmal so dieses Elektro-Swing-Gedöns und jetzt mit Babylon Berlin und La La Land ist ja auch nochmal so ein bisschen retro irgendwie, gerade total in, Mad Men, irgendwie immer mega erfolgreich. Vielleicht trittst du jetzt eine neue Design- und Kulturepoche an, einfach die Infantilitätsphase, wo man einfach wieder mit einem Letzchen rumläuft, wo man einfach die gute alte Rassel wieder ausmacht. Ich hole mir bald meinen Scout-Turnister zurück und einfach habe andauern so ein Warnwesten an. Und diese Armbänder, kennst du diese Knackarmbänder? Oh ja, diese Knackarmbänder. Oh, 100% könntest du das durchziehen. Wenn du das anfängst und lostrittst, eine komplette Kultur in Deutschland, in Infantilisierung. Aber so fängt doch auch Mode an, so Modetrends. Ich meine, fängt da so ein Kanye West an, dann irgendwie seine Jeans-Weste auf rechts oder links, halt auf die andere Seite zu tragen. Wer hat das eigentlich? Die ist auf rechts und links, das macht auch nicht Sinn, auf die umgekehrt, umgekrempeltheit. Links ist immer negativ gewandt. Also alles, was links ist, ist negativ direkt. Auf links ist falsch. Auf rechts ist genau dasselbe, aber es ist einfach... Linksextrem, alles falsch. Naja, und der fängt dann auch an und sagt dann sowas wie, Leute, ich fange jetzt einen neuen Trend an, könnt ihr bitte kurz einfach mitmachen? Fragt da so ein paar Freunde, die ja irgendwie auch ein bisschen Einfluss haben. Könnt ihr kurz mitmachen?
Und so ist es mit uns auch jetzt hier, mit den Podcast-Ufo-Hörern. Können wir nicht einfach mal alle so eine Infantilitätsphase starten? Einfach so findet auch Mode an, dass man sofort kurz macht, macht keine Sprüche drüber, komm, wir ziehen uns erstmal zusammen durch. Wir ziehen uns erstmal zusammen. Wie in La Ola. Jeder neue Umbruch, jede neue Revolution ist ein Leap of Faith. Man sagt einfach, komm, wir machen das jetzt einfach mal. Egal, ob das jetzt auf den ersten Blick sinnvoll und logisch erscheint. Man muss das erstmal machen, um dann rückwirkend die Situation zu erzeugen, wo man dann in 100 Jahren sagt, ja das war ja völlig selbstverständlich, dass diese neue Mode-Epoche entstanden ist. Aber in dem Moment, in dem sie entsteht, das nennt man, liebe Leute, das nennt man, was wir und die nicht gerade beschreiben, der La-Ola-Effekt. Du brauchst erstmal eine gewisse Grundgesamtheit einer Menge, die eine La-Ola startet, um den Gang zu setzen. Die wissen nicht, ob es eine gute Idee ist und wohin das führt, aber irgendwann ist es halt die La-Ola und dann ist es cool und alle freuen sich oder es scheitert halt. Es ist aber auch der Kafka-Effekt. Ja, aber mehr der La-Ola-Effekt. Vielleicht können wir es kombinieren, der Kafka-La-Ola-Effekt. Nämlich der Kafka-Effekt. Kafka-Ola. Sehr gut. Nämlich, dass du sagst, sobald Kafka da ist und du Kafka liest, kannst du die Autoren, die vor Kafka waren, alle interpretieren mit, ah, da hat sich dieser Stil von Kafka hier schon angeklungen und da hat man ja schon die ersten Regungen gesehen, die dann bei Kafka vollendet wurden. Das heisst, diese Autoren, die natürlich, weil sie vor Kafka kamen, nichts mit ihm zu tun haben, werden rückwärtend gelesen, werden rückwärtend gelesen als die Vorgänger von Kafka. Das heißt, das, was danach kommt, hat einen Einfluss auf die Vergangenheit. Und genauso ist es auch, dass wenn man jetzt einfach sagt, so man macht das jetzt, wird das von Kunsthistorikern interpretiert, als das war ja notwendig, weil man hat hier schon Anklänge gesehen. Die Anklänge kannst du dir immer dann zurecht reimen, weil du kannst alles irgendwie schon im Kern irgendwo mal angedeutet sehen, dass irgendwie dann keine Ahnung der Fidget Spinner, alle haben die Spielsachen in der Hand, kannst du dann auch sagen als ja, das war ja schon die Infantilisierung in ihren ersten Zügen, das hat dann Stefan Tietze einfach nur vollendet. Und dann ist so ein Bild nebenan von mir, wie ich mit so hochgesuchter Latzhose da stehe, mit einem Rucksack auf dem Rücken und so einem Luftballon in der Hand, mit so einem Riesen-Lolli, wow.
Die Kinder werden ja immer erwachsener, also mit sieben Jahren schon auf Tinder unterwegs und irgendwie schon mit Thong und Anzug unterwegs.
Thong.
Und dann wird es ja nur sinnvoll sein, wenn die Erwachsenen dann auch wieder kindischer werden.
Was man ja auch sehen kann, irgendwie alle schauen Zeichentrickserien, irgendwie, man ist, man bezieht sich mehr auf alltägliche Sachen, die wenigsten Leuten streben noch grossen Ideen hinterher, sondern auf Twitter-Post ist die, ich kann, ich habe heute so viel gegessen, bla bla bla, man, man, man, alles dreht sich so ein bisschen nach hinten. Tatsächlich ist der Rubik's Club ist mir neulich die Idee gekommen dafür, weil zum einen ist es cool, weil es echt beruhigend ist, zum anderen habe ich neulich im Netto jemand vor mir an der Kasse, wo ich mir dachte, wow, was ist bei ihm los. Manchmal sieht man da so Leute ganz kurz und denkt sich, wow, was ist seine Lebensgeschichte, was war es passiert die letzten Monate, was führt er, dass er jetzt hier mit mir im Netto steht. Und das war so ein Typ, der war bestimmt er, sagen wir mal, 25,
wilde Haare, wilder Bartwuchs und der war unfassbar
nervös und hat dann den Rubik's Cube in der Hand
und hat dann halt eingekauft und
nebenbei mit einer Hand den Rubik's Cube gelöst.
Wow, eine Hand? Ja, eine Hand nebenbei
und hat immer so mega nervös und dachte mir, das muss
ein Genie sein, weil er halt so,
sein Gehirn ist so unterbeansprucht mit seinem Scheiß
Einkaufen und so und dann hat er sich
Milch genommen und das genommen und dann habe ich mir
beobachtet, was er eingekauft hat, und es waren einfach Nudeln und Pesto, und ich dachte mir, wow, Stauleute essen Nudeln und Pesto, an dem Mann hat er wieder den Rigsgrub gelöst und so. Was ist Pesto? Bin ich mir nicht sicher, kommen wir gleich drauf zu sprechen, er kam zur Kasse, hat den Rigsgrub zum dritten Mal gelöst, und dann hat er seine, dann war er dran, musste bezahlen. Ich dachte mir, wow, wie bezahlt so ein Mensch mit Gedanken übertragen, Wahnsinn, nehmt Karte. Und dann hat er seine Karte abgegeben und reingesteckt und dann, ja bitte geben Sie einen Pin ein. Und er hat seinen Pin nicht gewusst. Und dann hat er nebenbei wieder seinen Rubikskub gelöst und ist so in sich gegangen und hat gesagt, ah, ich merke mir meinen Pin, er hat auch geschlottert die ganze Zeit aus der Stelle geredet, ich merke mir meinen Pin immer mit der Form, die das auf dem Ziffernfeld bildet. Und hat dann der Form seinen Pin gelöst. Und ich dachte mir, das ist zu Klischee gewesen jetzt. Du hast alles cool, spannender Charakter, ich hätte mir wahrscheinlich jetzt auch bei Nudeln und Pesto gekauft, weil ich genau so sein will wie du, weil du offensichtlich ein Genie bist, aber dann dieses, natürlich merkt sich doch irgendwie dann der Pin und das war schon ein bisschen lame, dann vor der Kasse dann so eine Nummer zu machen und zu sagen, ich weiß meine Pin nicht, geht so wirklich demonstrativ in sich, sagt, ich merke mir das über das Muster, was es auf dem Ziffernfeld ergibt, gibt es dann einen und die ganze Klasse, erwartet dann, dass alle klatschen oder was?
Das war lächerlich.
Das ist ein klassischer Zwei-von-Fünf-Sterne-Mensch.
Ein Runde zu viel.
Einfach, der es nicht zu Ende gedacht hat.
Aber es ist ganz spannend.
Ich habe mir tatsächlich lange,
als ich irgendwie, aus irgendeinem Grund war ich schon recht früh
im Banken- und Finanzwesen zu Hause.
Zu früh für viele, mit sechs Jahren zu früh.
Ich hatte schon, mein Vater, glaube ich,
hat mir irgendwie mit acht oder mit zehn oder so, hatte ich schon ein Konto, wo ich auch schon Geld hatte, hatte ich ein Konto mit fünf Mark und habe dann auch so einen grossen Ordner von der Sparkasse bekommen mit so Überweisungen, die ich ausfüllen kann und dann so Sachen. Ja, aber der Ordner, der war ein richtiger Ordner, da waren auch so Benjamin Blümchen da vorne drauf. Tatsächlich. Deine ersten Überweisungen. Ja, aber tatsächlich. Deine ersten Schulden. Deine ersten Fonds. Aber tatsächlich habe ich das einem Freund von mir gezeigt und der meinte, hä, das ist doch nur ein Spielzeugordner und ich, nee, das ist ein echter Ordner und der war auch ein echter Ordner, den ich immer noch habe. Und ist alles neu und tatsächlich habe ich da auch dann auch eine Geheimnummer bekommen. Und du hast ja früher diese Geldkarte bekommen, mit der du praktisch nichts machen konntest. Irgendwann hatte ich dann von der Sparkasse auch so ein Gerät, in das ich die Geldkarte schieben konnte. Und dann zeigte mir das Gerät an, wie viel Geld noch drauf ist. Und dann war da so drei Mark zwanzig. Und ich dachte, egal, ich habe drei Mark zwanzig. Aber nirgendwo konnte man mit dieser, wo das Geld auf der Karte war, direkt. Da hast du nochmal reingesteckt, drei Mark neunzehnt. Was? Was passiert hier? Schnell! Aber was konntest du damit machen? Nichts. Abheben? Nein. Wenn du mit deinen scheiß sechs Jahren da reinläufst und dann die Hände so auf den Tresen legst und dich so hoch schiebst, dann wird dir niemand deine drei Mark zwanzig auszahlen. Ja, aber bei Klaas hat es auch funktioniert, als Giro Hero. Oh mein Gott! Oh, mit Anlauf und gestolpert und gestolpert. Und da habe ich mir auch schon als Kind, weil ich dachte, als Kind immer, ich werde sofort gefangen und gefoltert, war immer so meine erste Assoziation, weil ich das Geheimwissen dieser Geheimnummer hatte. Ich dachte mir, fuck, jetzt bin ich wertvoll. Bis dahin wusste ich die fünf Power Ranger auswendig. Niemand klaut ein Kind, um sich zu fragen, wie die Power Ranger heissen. In dem Moment, in dem ich Geheimwissen hatte, dachte ich mir, shit, jetzt bin ich bedroht als Mensch. Ich werde entführt und gefoltert, damit jemand die Nummer hat. Und dann habe ich mir immer überlegt, wie kann ich mir die Nummer merken, auf eine Art, dass man sie nicht aus mir rausfoltern kann. Dass ich sie bestenfalls selber nicht weiß, aber schon auf eine Art weiss. Ist schon als Kind zu auf dem Foltern nachgedacht. Also ich dachte mir immer zum Beispiel, dass ich mir, wie gesagt, nur die Form merke, aber nicht weiss, wie rum. Also ob von oben oder von unten auf das Ziffern. Es ist ein bisschen blofer, weil du es selber nicht merken kannst. Weil du selber den falsch merkst, extra. Oh, aber da fällt mir ein, wir hatten in der Frank-Elster-Masterclass hatten wir mal eine ganz, ganz spannende Situation. Und zwar hatten wir die Situation, dass irgendjemand Wichtiges nicht im Büro war,
aber auf einem Laptop im Büro sein Passwort eingegeben werden musste.
Das heißt, wir hatten jetzt die Situation, wie übermittelt man das Passwort von einem Menschen an den anderen Menschen,
ohne dass die Empfängerperson das Passwort kennt, die es zwar eintippen kann, aber das Passwort nicht kennt. Und da haben wir lange überlegt, wie man das macht, weil das war ein ganz wichtiges Passwort. Trance. Trance, Hypnose wäre eine Möglichkeit gewesen. Und dann haben wir uns wirklich zusammengesetzt und überlegt und ich hatte dann die Idee, die einzige Möglichkeit, das zu machen, ist über mehrere Personen. Jeder weiss zwei Zahlen zum Beispiel. Genau, aber dann ist die Frage, wie ich sie reinfolge. Weil dann kann man sich ja als Gruppe wieder zusammensetzen und sagen, wir rekonstruieren mit uns. Es sei denn, du hast eine andere Figur, die unabhängig ist, die mit den Zahlen nie in Berührung kommt und die Leute random sortiert. Und jetzt kommst du rein und du rein. Aber sie darf ja nicht random sein, weil es muss ja die Reihenfolge. Ich dachte mir, du hast ein Zehnzeichen-Passwort, du hast zehn Räume, in denen zehn Leute kommen, die alle nur einen Buchstaben haben und die auch nicht wissen, in welcher Reihenfolge sie aus dem Raum genommen werden. Das heißt, du machst den Laptop schwarz, dass man nicht sieht, wie viele Zeichen schon eingetrippt wurden. Und manchmal jemanden rausnehmen, ihn aber zurückbringen. Zum Beispiel, genau. Oder man hat eine Stunde Zeit und dann lässt man erst mal 20 Minuten niemand, damit man denkt, ah, ich bin sicher nicht der Erste. Und das war die einzige Lösung. Aber dann kommt irgendwann raus, dass das Wort Diddle drin vorkam und Maus und 94 und dann fragt man sich auch, hm, welche Reihenfolge könnte das denn gewesen sein? Aber das heißt, die Person, die das Passwort hat, entscheidet, wer in welcher Reihenfolge aus den Räumen kommt, dann muss sie das Eintippen den Buchstaben, den nur die Person kennt und geht wieder in den Raum zurück, um nicht zu sehen, wer vor und wer nachher kommt. Das ist die einzige Lösung, die es gibt. Falls es eine bessere Lösung gibt, schreibt es in die Kommentare. Ich war ja immer mal morgens, kam ich zu spät und da waren, ich habe die Gags ausgewählt für den Stand-up und niemand hatte Gags für den Stand-up und dann kam ich ich zu spät morgen zum Niemagazin und dann wurde ich angerufen, wo ich dann bleiben würde, weil es gibt keine Gags. Es gibt keine Gags und das ist für mich auch eine Notsituation. Wir haben keine Gags mehr. Das ist einfach auch eine Notsituation. Das ist wie, hier liegt gerade jemand, der gleich stirbt, weil sein Herzschlag gegen null geht. Und dann wurde ich angerufen und musste mein Passwort verraten vor allem, weil bei mir im Programm halt die ganzen Gags drin waren. Und da habe ich auch kurz drüber nachgedacht, aber nach einer Sekunde mein Passwort verraten, in einer vollgeführten, total gefüllten U-Bahn, wo dann auch die Rückfrage kam, bitte kannst du es nochmal wiederholen, und ich laut durch die U-Bahn mein Passwort geschrieben hat. Und Jan Wimmermann, dass er nachher noch in seinem Podcast das Passwort verraten hat. Also das bin ich alles schiefgegangen. Wie lautet das Passwort? Das möchte ich nicht sagen. Ist immer noch von vielen Sachen mein Passwort.
Ich glaube, das ist die eigentliche Demütigung, nicht, dass jemand dein Passwort weiss, sondern dass jemand weiss, was dein Passwort ist, was du als Passwort ausgewählt hast und dann irgendwie, keine Ahnung, die hübsche Laura aus der Parallelklasse 64 und man denkt sich, oh Gott, die Laura wirklich? Aber mir gefällt das Finanzwesen in der Jugend, weil es ist dann, du wirst nicht, ich wollte immer gut behandelt werden, auch als jemand wirklich vollwertiger Kunde. Dann bin ich da reingegangen in die Bank, in die Sparkasse, hab mich schlau gefühlt, hab mir auch eine Krawatte angezogen und einen Sakko und dann hast du einfach ein Jeans-Sparbuch. Dann hast du ein Jeans-Sparbuch. Das hat Stoff. Mein Sparbuch hat nichts. Ich will, gib mir doch ein Normales. Gib mir dieses Standard hässlichen Dinger. Nicht den mit dem Flüschbären obendrauf, mit dem Teddybärenstoff. Nein, dann kriegst du einfach ein Jeans-Sparbuch oder ein Knacks-Sparbuch. Das ist alles so. Kann ich nicht einfach ein Giro? Ich will ein Girokonto haben. Ist aber ein interessanter Punkt. In manchen Aspekten wollen Kinder erwachsen sein, in manchen aber nicht. Also wie gesagt, als Kind hast du dann den Turtles Rucksack, den Schulranzen, aber willst vielleicht nicht den Turtles Sparbuch haben. Nee, du willst nicht das Turtles Sparbuch. Weil da willst du dann erwachsen sein, aber in manchen Sachen nicht, weil du könntest ja auch schon sagen, ich will einen Erwachsenen Rucksack haben. Da willst du aber den Turtles Rucksack, weil ist. Kinder sind inkongruent, lass uns da, das ist schon viel. Kinder sind verwirrt. Ich war auch verwirrt, dann habe ich irgendwann angefangen zu sammeln, habe ich mal Edelsteine gesammelt, habe ich mal, keine Ahnung, irgendwelche Sachen gesammelt und dann habe ich irgendwann die Euros gesammelt, aus allen Euro-Ländern. Habe ich auch, habe ich auch zu Hause noch so ein Club-Ding. Ja, ein Club-Ding und da hat man dann aus allen Euro-Ländern die gespeiert. Und irgendwann kam dann die andere Phase, ich sammle was anderes und brauche Geld für was anderes. Hundertprozentig das Gleiche bei mir auch. Das Problem ist aber, dass du in der Phase davor Geld gesammelt hast. Also irgendwann fiel dann auch den Eltern mal auf und den Verwandten, meine Tante arbeitete nämlich bei der Bank, die hat mir dann das mitgebracht. Und irgendwann fiel auf, ich bin ja am Wochenende da, dann habe ich ihnen das gezeigt, oh, schon fast voll. Und jetzt habe ich es voll. Das Wochenende danach war es dann nicht mehr voll. Da war dann, da fehlte dann schon zwei Euro Stück von Estland. Ups, Moment, du hattest es nicht wirklich voll, du hattest nicht Vatikanstaat, du hattest nicht einen Cent Vatikanstaat, forget it. Ich habe vielleicht nicht Vatikanstaat,, aber so ungefähr voll irgendwann war dann in Finnland das zwei Euro Stück weg.
Oh ja, Finnland war gut. Dann war irgendwann
das Belgien zwei Euro, der komische Typ.
Schweden, das waren die Gänse drauf, ne?
Ich fand Griechenland toll, dann war plötzlich die Eule weg.
Ups, das war
und dann irgendwann wurde es immer leerer, immer leerer,
weil Geld sammeln ist echt das
dümmste der Welt. Bei mir tatsächlich exakt dasselbe.
Mir war es aber so, dass ich sogar noch
während der Phase, in der ich diese Münzen gesammelt hatte, aber mir auch manchmal halt einfach eine Packung Colorado kaufen wollte. Ja, genau, das ist das Problem. Und dann, was ist mir wichtiger wichtig? Meine fucking Verfressenheit? Oder irgendwie das, das, das, das, ich meine, Belgien, komm schon, Belgien ein Euro. Die sieht man häufiger und niemand weiß, was dieser Typ da hinten drauf soll. Die kriege ich schon wieder, auch vor allem, dass es zwei Arten von Ländern gab, die, die überall dasselbe Motiv drauf haben. Ohne Scheiß, Irland, Irland, Alter, Harfe, auf allem Harfe, ihr habt doch die, ihr habt viel. Ihr habt Kobolde, ihr habt vierblattige Kleeblätter, ihr habt alles St. Patrick's Gedöns, warum immer nur die Harfe? Ich hätte nicht mal die Harfe damit verbunden. Kleeblatt, klar, klar. Es wäre so viel möglich gewesen. Stimmt, viele Länder. Frankreich war ganz abgefahren, aber jetzt so gesetzt, die hatten diesen Baum, der so mit verschiedenen Achterbahnen mittlerweile nicht mehr drauf war. Italien, da Vinci auch drauf. Irgendwann wurde es verfremdet, weil dann kamen jetzt die Sonderzeichen und die Köln und dann hat jedes Bundesland eine eigene Münze bekommen und so, da wurde es dann irgendwann abgefahren.
Vor allem ist es ja so, wir leben ja in einer Zeit, in der Helden fallen wie Fliegen. Die Menschen, zu denen man jahrelang aufgeschaut hat, liegen plötzlich im Dreck. Harvey Weinstein ist gefallen, Bill Cosby ist gefallen, in Amerika ist gerade eine grosse Debatte über die Statuen von den Konföderierten, Generälen. Soll man die verehren oder ist das moralisch fragwürdig? Das ist natürlich auch eine interessante Frage zu historischen Figuren. Da Vinci, wir haben es schon mal angesprochen, war da alles koscher bei dem. Wenn jetzt rauskommen würde, da Vinci hat irgendwie der Assistenten mal oder den Rock gefasst, muss Italien die Euromünze neu prägen. Da Vinci-Code hat plötzlich eine ganz andere Bedeutung, Tom Hanks kann sich nicht mehr sehen lassen, plötzlich ist alles kaputt, plötzlich alle coolen Sachen, die früher in allen Museen, muss Da Vinci abgehängt werden. Man kann plötzlich sagen, der Hubschrauber, müssen wir den nochmal überdenken, Da Vinci hat den Hubschrauber entdeckt, kann man plötzlich sagen, als Sanitäter kann ich noch guten Gewissens in den Hubschrauber steigen. Wie sah sein Hubschrauber aus? Da Vinci hat einen Hubschrauber erfunden. Was denn für einen Hubschrauber? Er hat auch Flügel erfunden, die man sich so anklebt, wo man dann, wo ich dachte, was andererseits ein Hubschrauber, der hatte so eine große Spirale auf dem Kopf und dann dreht man diese Spirale durch und hat so eine Schraube so in die Luft geschraubt. Alter, wie dumm muss man sein? Da Vinci war schon voll idiotio. Man muss sagen, und er hat einen Menschen gemalt. Okay, wow. Dann plötzlich macht er die Beine ein bisschen auseinander, und dann hat er den Kreis rumgemalt. Ich glaube, da Vinci ist auch so ein Typ, da haben einfach so viele Leute gesagt, komm, lass ihn machen, lass ihn Leonardo da machen in seine scheisse Werkstatt kommen. Es haben so viele Leute gesagt, dass es irgendwann so ein Abgekulte wird. Niemand weiß nachher, ob jemand ironisch abgekultet wurde oder nicht. Das weiss niemand nachher. Stimmt, das ist wie Pietro Lombardi, wo heute viele Leute Tweets raushauen und sagen, er ist der beste Sänger der Welt. Irgendwann steht in Südstaaten, Alabama und in Pietro Lombardi-Statue. Oh shit, Leute, wir haben es übertrieben. Aber ganz im Ernst, dieses Da Vinci-Ding mit diesem Kreis, das ist doch offensichtlich Bullshit. Mit dem Kreis in den Menschen. Wenn du die Arme und die Beine rotierst, stell dir mal die Beine vor. Ich verstehe auch nicht, wo noch so ein bisschen was zu nennen. Der Bein, ein Beinlänge ist Radius, aber du hast hier den Hüftknochen zwischen den Beinen. War das das erste Dickpick eigentlich? Das erste, dass er eine Frau gegeben hat, so, das bin ich. Ich trage immer diese langen Mäntel, deswegen sieht man nicht, wie gut ich gebaut bin, das bin ich.
Das ist der erste Ding, das erste Ding vielleicht, was er, ist eh nicht er selber.
Das ist doch wirklich einfach falsch,
dass es einen Kreis ergibt.
Ich muss sagen, die Proportionen
scheinen schon zu stimmen, auf eine Art.
Ach so, dass wenn
du die ausstreckst,
ich weiß nur, ich weiß nur, dass wenn du
die Arme ausstreckst, dass deine Körpergröße ergibt. Ungefähr exakt genau wie deine Elle, äh, nee, von deinem Ellenbogen bis zu deinem Handgelenk deine Schuhgröße ist. Exakt. Ja, aber nicht, aber auch nur so halb. Auch nur so halb. Das ist immer wie dieses mit diesem goldenen Schnitt, den du einfach irgendwie einfach auf einem Random Stock bildst, du den goldenen Schnitt drauf. Wow, die Linie trifft hier genau den Typen die Akte und da nochmal die Frau, die nicht im Chefbüro sein darf. Wow, toll. Dieses Bild von der Spirale, wo die Spirale halt immer genau größer wird. Ja, das kannst du einfach skalieren. Genau, das kannst du einfach machen, wie du willst. Und vor allem bei tausend Bildern von tausend Schneckenhäusern findest du halt mal eins, wo es drauf ist. Was wir euch sagen wollen. Glaubt nicht,
was ihr seht. Traut euren Augen nicht.
Widerlegt, der goldene Schnitt ist widerlegt.
Widerlegt die ganze Zeit.
Diese Scheisspirale nervt mich.
Immer dieser Bullshit.
Ich hätte mal nicht auch an der ganzen Menschheit an mir selber gezweifelt.
Da bin ich zur Arbeit gelaufen morgens,
schön, Musik auf dem Ohr, Kaffeebecher in der Hand.
Und dann wurde der Bürgersteig plötzlich schmal,
weil rechts so ein Stromkasten war. Da kam halt ein Mensch entgegen. Und dann habe ich Platz gemacht für den Menschen. Und dann hatte der Mensch aber noch einen Hund dahinter, der sich halt extrem viel Zeit gelassen hat. Und dann habe ich halt gewartet für den Hund. Und der Hund ist ganz langsam an einem Stromkasten vorbeigelaufen, ganz langsam. Und ich dachte mir so, das ist gerade mein, ich warte gerade, ich bin ein Mensch. Ich muss auf den Hund warten, dass er endlich geht, damit ich an dem Stromkasten vorbeigehen kann und weitergehen kann. Ich habe so nach auf diesen Hund gewartet, dass ich mal kurz irgendwie die ganze Reihenfolge der, was ist ja eigentlich die hauptsächliche Spezies auf diesem Planeten überdacht habe und so weiter, was ist denn da los gewesen? Hättest du denn für ein Kind auch gewartet? Ja, für ein Kind schon. Aber bei Kindern, manchmal behandle ich Kinder absichtlich schlecht, weil ich mir denke, die sollen eine Lektion lernen. Nee, komm. Nein, das machst du, damit du es einfacher hast in der Situation. Ich behandle sie jetzt wie schlecht im Sinne, es war kein Scherz. Ich denke mir schon manchmal, wenn ich zum Beispiel, wenn ein Kind auf dem Boden guckt und über die Gehweg läuft, dann laufe ich manchmal direkt auf das Kind zu, ich werde es nicht umchecken, aber so dass das Kind Aber du lebst aktiv deine Laufbahn aufs Kind zu. Ja. Dann sagen die Eltern doch auch, haben die ja völlig Schaden. Nein, nein, ich laufe nicht aktiv auf das Kind zu, aber wo ich bei einem Erwachsenen höflich ausweichen würde, mache ich das bei einem Kind nicht direkt, weil ich mir denke, das Kind geht sonst durchs Leben und denkt, es kann einfach überall hinlaufen. Und ein Kind sitzt jetzt von so einem Radiogerät, wo es uns hört, das darf ich, ich hab's gewusst, ich hab das gewusst, es gibt so eine Kinderfraktion zusammengerufen mit ihren scheißigen Dienstsparbüchern, rufen sie hier zusammen und rufen sie an über eine Telefonketten mit ihrem grossen Handy. Nein, ich finde, bei der Strasse gilt, jeder weicht zur Hälfte aus. Wenn man aufeinander zugeht, jeder weicht zur Hälfte aus. Und manchmal bin ich natürlich auch sehr gerne gewillt, 100 Prozent auszuweichen, wenn der andere ein Arschloch ist. Kein Problem. Bei Kindern bin ich nicht so gerne gewillt, 100 Prozent auszuweichen, weil ich mir denke, die müssen das gerade noch lernen. Woher soll der denn wissen, dass er selber ausweichen muss, wenn alle immer sagen, ach, das ist ja Kind, natürlich der da vorbei. Ich mache mal, ich laufe wie gesagt nicht um, aber ich möchte schon, dass das Kind merkt, dass es gerade dadurch, dass es auf den Boden geguckt hat, wichtige Informationen der Umwelt verpasst hat und dann auch ausweichen. Oder was ich manchmal mache, wenn man morgens an der U-Bahn steht und man wartet auf die U-Bahn und so, einfach mal ein Kind, wenn es zu dicht am Gleis steht, einfach mal aufs Gleis schubsen. Einfach mal aufs Gleis schubsen, damit es merkt, guck mal, das kann passieren, wenn du zu nah am Gleis stehst. Ey, wenn ein Kind über die Straße läuft und nicht sieht, dass dein Auto kommt, halte ich das Kind manchmal einfach gerne fest, sodass das Auto dagegen fährt. Komm, fahr ruhig! Fahr ruhig! Fahr ruhig! Das muss ein Lektion erlernen! Gern das Kind auch noch mal wirklich mit richtiger Kraft gegen das Auto werfen, weil es hätte ja nicht gebremst. Ja, oder einfach mal oben in dieses, bei Babys gerne gemacht, einfach oben in dieses Loch, in dieses Schädelloch reindrücken. Gott. Weil, einfach weil, ist doch deren Problem, dass es nicht zuwächst, schnell genug. Was, Kinder haben Loch im Kopf? Ja. Die haben weichen Kopf oben. Nee, da will ich jetzt nicht anfangen, weil die noch keinen Schädel haben. Ja, weil der Schädel ... Ja, das ist wie dieses Spiel, wo man in so eine Kiste greifen muss, wo man dann dieses
fühlt, fühl was es ist mässig, kannst du so oben bei denen in den Schädel greifen.
Was?
Oh, komm mal auf.
Wer ist das denn, Fratella?
Deswegen dürfen die auch kein Fratella, wie heißt das denn nochmal, die Flanelle?
Dann der Ton, als wird der Teil der Tesser Fratella.
Wer ist das denn nochmal, Flanella, nee Flanelle? Lamella. Nee, die Flan, Babyloch im Kopf. Oh Gott, da kommen ganz merkwürdige Bilder, Stefan, bitte. Ich muss gucken, was es heißt, die Fratella. Fontanelle. Naja, Fontanelle war gut? Fontanella. Oh, ich hätte gerne eine, die Google Schachatello und Fontanella. Quattro Fontanello.
Ja, wächst noch zu, der Schädelknochen wächst zu.
Ja, aber dann darf man seinen Kindern ja auch keine Hüte aufsetzen, oder?
Gerade Hut, gerade Hut. Oder immer einen Helm.
Immer einen Helm.
Der Schädel passt sich dann noch an den Hut an.
Kann gut sein.
Ich sehe ja komplett bescheuert aus, wenn ein Kind die ganze Zeit so einen dummen Hut hat.
Hellefriere so einen Topf, ich habe ein Foto von mir entdeckt, ich hatte einfach einen Topfschnitt, einfach einen blonden Topfschnitt und es ist perfekt für Kinder einfach. Die fallen weich, die sehen lächerlich aus, die werden nicht bevorzugt im Leben, die werden von Leuten wie die umgerannt im Straßenverkehr, die lernen ihre Lektionen. Vor allem bei vielen genialen Erfindungen denkt man ja, das ist ja selbstverständlich, da wäre früher oder später ohnehin jemand draufgekommen. Bei allen Sachen denke ich mir das, Treppe zum Beispiel. Irgendwann muss ja jemand die Idee gehabt haben, Treppe, aber da nicht mehr gut, das wäre früher oder später gekommen. Der richtige Treppenabstand wäre mal interessant. Vor allem was eine furchtbare Zeit, wo das nicht genormt war. Ja! Wo das nicht genormt war. Und es gibt eine Treppe irgendwo tatsächlich, ich weiß nicht, ich habe vergessen wo, wo eine Stufe grösser ist, wo alle immer stolpern. Genau. Und da hat mal jemand so eine GoPro aufgestellt, sehr lustig, weil da immer jemand stolpert. Das Einzige, was ich in der Welt sehe, wo ich mir denke, das ist nicht selbstverständlich, sind tatsächlich Hüte. Hätte nie jemand damit angefangen, Hut zu tragen. Bitte was, Sonnenschutz? Nein, aber das ist nicht selbstverständlich. Sonnenschutz hältst du halt die Hand in den Kopf. Der natürliche Hut ist die Hand. Was ich gar nicht selbstverständlich finde und auch finde, so ein Luxusgut ist, sind die flachen Rolltreppen. Die flachen Rolltreppen, das Wort ist nicht mehr existent, aber ein Flughäfen. Laufband. Oh, genial! Du bist schneller am Gate. Und dass Leute, die darauf stehen bleiben, haben das nicht verstanden. Es ist schon zum Gehen, nur halt du bist schneller beim Gehen. Das ist einfach eine geniale Idee. Auch ein Luxusgut, was man nicht unbedingt braucht. Seid einfach pünktlich am Gate. Kann man da nicht einfach so einen Skilift machen, wo man sich reinsetzen kann, am Flughafen? Das fände ich gut, aber mit dem ganzen Gepäck. Ne, das gibt es ja ab vorher. Finde ich schon okay, finde ich schon okay. Ich wollte gerade was sagen, was ich jetzt vergessen habe, irgendwie. Oder für ein rotes Katapult, wo man sich reinsetzt und dann zum Gate geschossen wird. Ich habe eben über Kinder gesprochen. Das ist jetzt interessant, dass dir gerade zu Kindern nichts einfällt, wo du doch gerade selber in der Kindheitsphase bist. Ich bin nicht in der Kindheitsphase. Du bist mega in der Kindheitsphase. Ich habe ein Rubik's Cube, das ist ein Hipster-Gegenstand. Ich finde vor allem das Geräusch ist so beruhigend, oder? Findest du das nicht? Kannst du jetzt mal lösen, wie lange brauche ich... ab jetzt! Wow, das waren drei Sekunden fünfzig. Alter, was ist der Weltrekord? Das ist der fucking... was ist der Weltrekord? Ich glaube, so vier Sekunden oder was? Fuck, Alter. What? Reicht... Oh mein Gott, es reicht! Holyi... Aber reicht das als Beweis? Oh mein Gott, Leute! Ich habe geguckt, es waren genau drei Sekunden fünfzig. Fuck, Alter! Yes, ey! Wie geil ist das denn, Mensch? Herzlichen Glückwunsch! Danke, ey. Siehste, von wegen Kindheitsphase. World Record! Nicht schlecht, ey. Meinst du, du kriegst das nochmal hin?
Klar.
Aber du musst ihn erst vertauschen, so.
Okay, jetzt der Beweis.
Auf die Plätze, fertig, los!次回予告 Bisschen langsamer.
Bisschen langsamer.
Genie.
Weltrekord. Kriegen wir noch richtig einen Weltrekord hin aufzustellen?
Ich glaube, es ist mega leicht, einen Weltrekord aufzustellen.
Das ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Das ist eine neue Kategorie für einen.
Jojo in das tiefste Loch geworfen der Welt.
Immer auch Würde. Diese Menschen haben auch Würde. Du fährst zum tiefsten Loch der Welt, das ist irgendwo, keine Ahnung, in Afrika, in so einer Höhle, dann wirfst du dann Jojo runter und dann sagst du das am tiefsten geworfene Jojo unter Meeresspiegel. Du hast doch gesagt, die Haltung ist auch die gleiche, die ist komm, komm. Und wirfst einfach rein und hab ich jetzt... Tock... Toc. Es muss immer ein Notar dabei sein, oder? Dieser arme Guinness-Buch der Rekorde Notar, der irgendeine dumme Scheiß-Orte der Welt fliegen muss. Nur damit irgendein Typ sich irgendwie sechs Hot-Docs reindrückt und dann nach drei übergibt er sich und dann, okay, ciao, ich pack's ja wieder, ne, macht's gut. Und dafür bin ich nach Nepal gereist. Nee. Soll ich wirklich kommen? Ja, wir schaffen sechs Hot-Docs. Kannst du esist. Soll ich wirklich kommen? Ja, wir schaffen sechs Hot Dogs. Kannst du es wirklich? Soll ich wirklich kommen? Hast du es schon mal probiert zumindest? Das ist nämlich die erste Frage. Ja, das ist nicht so schwer. Hast du es schon mal probiert? Ich fahr jetzt los. Ich fahr jetzt los nach Nepal. Darf man eine Vergangenheit haben in diesem Bereich? Darfst du so eine professionelle Hot Dog-Es-Vergangenheit haben? Ja, schon, oder? Ich glaube, Kindesburg ist nicht auf Amateure begrenzt.
Nee, weil das war immer ganz hart.
Wenn du das so, dass du nicht professioneller Baggerfahrer sein, wenn du mit dem Bagger die Nasenhaare entfernen wolltest.
Hm.
Wo hast du denn den Bagger her?
Ja genau, das haben wir mich auch gefragt, nämlich.
Danke, dass du die richtigen Fragen stellst. Das ist schon interessant. Ganz merkwürdig. Aber das war auch so ein Ding, da hat einer jemals mal eine Wette mit einem Bagger gemacht und dann haben sich ganz viele Leute gedacht, mit einem Bagger könnte man auch. Wäre das ein Gabelstapler gewesen, wäre die Gabelstaplerwette legendär für Wetten das. Das ist einfach so der Erste, der es macht und alle orientieren sich dran. Das hätte auch ein Flugzeug sein können.
Auf jeden Fall, auch bis heute fragwürdig, warum das so erfolgreich war.
Es ist halt so ein bisschen dieses, man gibt irgendwie Raum, es ist nicht zu spannend, du hast halt nebenbei Raum für Gespräche.
Das Baseballgeheimnis, es plätschert so dahin.
Es plätschert so dahin, hat halt Raum für Strecke machen.
Ich glaube, du musst in der Gute Schaut immer Raum zum Strecke machen, mit coolen Gästen, Prominenten, die einfach mal reden können.
Alles andere ist so nebenbei, wenn es jetzt die Wetten zu spannend gewesen wären. Du hast ja gesehen, Samuel Koch hat die ganze Sendung ruiniert, weil es einfach plötzlich zu sehr im Mittelpunkt stand. Es ist was passiert. Weil er sich in den Mittelpunkt gestellt hat mit seinem Scheiß. Und dann waren plötzlich alle Menschen, Tom Cruise musste dann eher gehen und so. Das wollte doch niemand sehen. Man sagt ja zu solcher Art von Sendungen immer so Lagerfeuer-Sendungen, wo alle zusammenkommen, jetzt im konkreten Fall die Familie vorm Fernseher, als auch im abstrakten Fall das ganze Land sitzt zusammen vorm Fernseher und genießt das. Und Lagerfeuer zeichnet ja aus, das ist nicht super spannend, das sind Lagerfeuer. Ne, man schläft auch meistens ein beim Lagerfeuer. Total, und es ist warm, aber es ist ein Anlass, um sich zusammenzusetzen. Und es ist so von einer Seite warm. Also vielleicht überstoppert sich jetzt die Betapher, aber es ist so von einer Seite sehr warm, sehr heiß, danach riechen die Klamotten tagelang nach Rauch.
Ich glaube, du vernetzt nicht.
Und dann ist es meistens auch wirklich, man schläft dabei ein und dann zieht es meistens irgendwie ein Zelt rein und dann ist...
Ich glaube, es ist...
Ich lasse mich wieder hin.
Okay, beruhige dich.
Setze her.
Und ich glaube, das ist einfach...
Zum Beispiel im Kino bringt Leute nicht zusammen, weil ein Kino ist zu interessant, der Film ist zu interessant. Beim Lagerfeuer ist es anders und deswegen muss gutes Fernsehen, das Menschen verbindet, darf nicht zu spannend sein. Nee, gute Filme sind nicht zu gut. Ja, so ist es. Die dürfen nicht zu gut sein, dann sitzt du da mit offenem Mund die ganze Zeit und denkst dir, wow. Und vergisst alles um dich herum. Vergisst es herum, ja. Stimmt schon, so eine Mittelmäßigkeit gehört dazu. Und auch lange, bis so ein Lagerfeuer immer aus ist, och, noch und klotzt und noch ein Klotz rein. Und noch so ein Scheit, ein Holzscheit. Hol noch ein Scheit. Was? Der erste Mensch, der das Wort gesagt hat. Was soll ich holen, Schatz? Ein Scheit. Ich hol noch Holz, okay? Nee, hol doch bitte einen Scheit. Wir brauchen noch ein oder zwei Scheite. Was ist das, zwei Holzstücke? Was ist Scheit? Ein Scheit ist ein Holzstück, ja. Warum bleiben wir nicht mit dem Wort, was wir vorher genutzt haben? Naja, weil wir das Holz ja auseinandergeschieden haben, also ist es ein Scheit. Aber mit T schreibt man das, nicht mit D. Du sagst die ganze Zeit mittlerweile neue Worte.
Du kannst dir einfach neue Worte sagen. Ach ja, das ist, finde ich jetzt aber auch ein bisschen kniffrig von dir. Wie nennst du das, was wir am Sofa stehen haben? Dieses, wie nennst du das, wo man seine Beine drauflegt beim Sofa? Chaiselon. Warum nennst du es nicht, wie wir es vorher genannt haben? Teil vom Sofa. Ne, Chaiselon. Otto, wenn man einen Sessel kauft, hat man dieses Fussbein, was Ottomane heißt. Ottomane? Ottomane. Das ist doch das Volk, die Automatone. Vielleicht wurde ich wieder geprankt. Stefan wurde schon wieder geprankt. Die längste Auflösung der Welt. Als Ottomane bezeichnet man ursprünglich eine sofaähnliche gepolsterte Sitzbank mit halbrunden Armlehnen. Ursprünglich und dann irgendwann wurde es dann zu diesem Teil, wo man die Füsse drauflegt. Ich habe eine Frage an dich, Stefan. Legst du die Füsse hoch? Ja? Typischer Fusshochleger, klar, auf jeden Fall. Ich lege die Füsse ganz selten hoch. Echt nicht? Ich glaube, es liegt an dem Ort, wo du bist. Ich habe nämlich so eine L-förmige Schlafcouch, wo ich auf dem Ende des L-Stückes kann ich gut meine Füsse hochlegen. Viele haben halt nur diese klassische I-förmige Couch, wo vorne drauf ein Tisch ist. Man legt selten die Beine auf den Tisch, weil das unbequem ist. Der Tisch ist auch voll immer. Klar, immer voller Kram. Was ist bei dir auf dem Tisch? Bei mir auf dem Tisch leere Flaschen und ein Topf. Benutzte Kondome, Infusion, komischer Ort. Nee. Aber wenn du dich auf eine Couch legst, um Film zu schauen, eine klassische Couch, setzt du dich dann so auf die Couch und schaust den Fernseher frontal an, oder bist du jemand, der sich dann so vers Sofa legt, längs und dann so nach rechts guckt? Deswegen die L-Form. Die beides kombiniert. Genau, die beides kombiniert und am Ende des Ls quasi ist der Fernseher, er ist also nicht mittig der Couch, sondern eher Richtung L zentriert, also du kannst dich hinlegen. Auf der Pannschlein. Genau, richtig, das macht schon Sinn. Es gibt faszinierende Menschen, es gibt die Menschen, die sich hinlegen, und also angenommen, irgendwann wird es ja später und es ist schon später, der Film ist ja fast vorbei und manche Leute legen sich auf die Couch, auf eine ganz normale E-Family Couch, in der Mitte ist zentriert der Fernseher. Die legen sich hin und gucken und schlafen dann schon so fast weg und gucken dann halt, also der Körper liegt ja quasi horizontal und der Fernseher wird dann umgekehrt angeguckt, also der ist einmal um 90 Grad gekippt. Das kann ich gar nicht nachvollziehen. Manche Menschen schaffen es aber auch irgendwie müde zu sein und sich hinzulegen, aber der Oberkörper dreht sich noch so hoch. Heißt, dass das Gesicht wohl noch gerade ist. Wie so ein Wurm, der aus dem Abfischbaut. Wie Jabba the Hutt. Einfach wie Jabba the Hutt liegen sie auf der Couch. Und das finde ich beides nicht nachvollziehbar. Ich bin ein klassischer, ich muss mich gerade hinsetzen Typ. Ist für Schnecken echt ein Problem, die liegen immer. Die können sich nie mal entspannen. Und Krebsen gucken immer in die falsche Richtung. Flundern sind das einzig asymmetrische Tier. Das stimmt. Das ist eine ganz faszinierende Sache zu sein. Weil die haben beide Augen, ah, das ist so strange. Weil eigentlich, der Mensch ist ja tatsächlich, läuft ja noch nicht so lange aufrecht. Deswegen haben viele Menschen Rückenprobleme und wissen nicht, wie sie sich halten sollen. Das ist ein chronisches Ding bei Menschen, weil einfach der Körper nicht so perfekt. Viele Menschen laufen falsch rum, weil sie nicht wissen, wie es da läuft. Weil tatsächlich der Körper noch nicht so perfekt gebaut ist zum Aufrechtgehen. Aber mit dem Stehen kommt ja das Liegen. Der Mensch, der liegt, der steht, damit eröffnest du ja nicht nur die Dimension nach oben, sondern auch nach unten. Du kannst dich entspannt hinsetzen. Der steht, der liegt. Ja, wohingegen jetzt irgendwie so ein Jaguar, für den ist es nicht so ein krasser Act, sich hinzulegen, weil der liegt ja eh schon fast, wenn er steht. Der Mensch hingegen macht nochmal eine krasse Dimension, auf weil er sich wirklich entspannen kann, sich hinzulegen kann. Eine Schnecke,
absolute Katastrophe, die Schnecke, die sich nie mal entspannt hinlegen kann. Er senkt dann halt
so den Kopf vielleicht ein bisschen und liegt den Kopf
so auf dem Boden, wenn sie müde ist. Die liegt die ganze Zeit.
Schlangen. Haben Schlangen,
können die auch sitzen? Haben die
auch so eine Zwischenebene, zwischen stehen?
Die können so ein bisschen ihren Kopf nach oben recken,
aber ich glaube, das ist anders. Ist das deren Sitzen, das Stehen?
Ich glaube, so eine Kobra kann wirklich sich so
wirklich aufrecht hinstellen,
wohingegen andere Schlangen sich nur so ein bisschen nach oben
Vielen Dank. Die können so ein bisschen ihren Kopf nach oben recken, aber ich glaube, das ist anders. Ist das deren Sitz noch stehen? Ich glaube, so eine Kobra kann wirklich sich so wirklich aufrecht hinstellen, wohingegen andere Schlangen sich nur so ein bisschen nach oben biegen können, aber nicht wirklich aufrecht stehen. Ich glaube, eine Kobra ist relativ entspannt, wenn die so entsteht. Ich habe auch noch eine Chamäleonphase gehabt vor meiner Kinderphase, die war strange, weil es gibt so faszinierende Videos von Chamäleons, weil erst mal haben die crazy Hände, die haben so, die haben einfach wie so Zangenhände. Z wie so Zangenhände, die haben wie keine Finger, die haben einfach nur so, wenn ihr alle vier Finger und den Daumen, wenn die Finger zusammen nimmt und den Daumen in die andere Richtung abspreizt. Ja, wie so ein Fäustling-Handschuh. Ja, genau, richtig, wie so ein Boxhandschuh, theoretisch. Und dann stehen die halt, haben die hinten auch und dann stehen die manchmal so und können sich halt so wegbiegen und dann greifen die immer nach den nächsten Dingen mit ihren komischen Handen und dann kommen die halt in Terrarien nicht klar, weil die Wände aufs Glas sind, aber die halten einfach bestimmt zehn Minuten lang durch, um zu gucken, ob sie nicht doch irgendwo was finden. Heißt, die frabbeln die ganze Zeit rum. Ohne Pantomime eigentlich mit so der Glaswand. Und man haben Leute herausgefunden, dass man denen alles in die Hand drücken kann. Man kann denen so Spielzeugechste in die Hand drücken und die nehmen die halt sofort. Man kann denen Spielzeugschwerte in die Hand drücken und die nehmen die sofort. Helme, die haben letterlich verkleidet alle. Furchtbare Tekelreihe. Und dann kann man die auch Richtung Wasserhahn bringen, indem die auf dem Zeigefinger sitzen mit den Hinterpfoten. Und dann kannst du die so Richtung laufenden Wasserhahn geben und dann versuchen die halt zehn Minuten lang das Wasser zu greifen, weil die halt weiterlaufen wollen. Das ist eine ganz faszinierende Spezies. Alter, wie limitiert man sein kann, um trotzdem Millionen Jahre zu überleben. Die haben das, was sie brauchen können müssen. Ja, und dann, jetzt wo wir gerade beim Liegen waren, ich finde es faszinierend, wie Leute dann nach und nach die Abendroutine beginnen, ins Bett gehen, mit dem Laptop nochmal ins Bett, eine Serie gucken gucken, Folge Fargo und dann irgendwann hinlegen. Genau, immer kleiner werden die Bildschirme, okay, und dann manchmal, also ich habe zum einen den Laptop auf Bauch, Kissen schön hinten dran an die Rückwand des Bettes, noch aufrechtlich. Laptop auf Bauch? Genau. Aha. Ja. Also, dass man quasi sich aufrichtet, im Bett hinten, an der Rückwand sitzt, Laptop auf Bauch Richtung Schrittgegend und dann kann man noch was gucken. So, dann irgendwann wird mir das dann, ist das mir zu aktiv, da bin ich noch zu aktiv, dann geht es irgendwann Richtung halb zwölf, dann kommt der Laptop, wird umgedreht, quasi auf die Matrasse gestellt und ich lege mich auf den Bauch und gucke noch.
Dann irgendwann wird es noch später
und meine Augen fallen schon so zu. Heißt,
ich will eigentlich schon liegen.
Da muss ich meinen Kopf ja auch aufrichten, da bin ich ja auch
quasi aufgerichtet. Also irgendwann
lege ich mich dann hin, seitlich, auf die Seite.
Und der Laptop wird gekippt
und weil er ja im 90-Grad-Winkel
aufgeklappt ist, wird er seitlich hingestellt und ich gucke seitlich auf den Monitor und gucke noch eine Serie. Ich habe herausgefunden, dass es niemand macht anderes. Ich kenne niemanden, der das macht. Ich habe es Leuten gesagt, ich dachte, das wäre das Normalste der Welt, aber man sieht halt selten andere Leute dabei. Und das macht tatsächlich niemand, weil die kommen damit nicht klar. Das mache ich aber auch manchmal, ja, tatsächlich. Das mache ich sehr häufig. Aber dann ist für mich der Punkt so, da mache ich auch nicht mehr lange so, weil dann ist eh schon durch. Nein, aber das ist auch nicht gedacht zum Lange machen mehr. Dann wird es zu jemandem zugeklappt und dann wird noch ein Podcast gehört. Aber ich starte tatsächlich immer direkt auf dem Bauch. Ich liege auf dem Bauch und Laptop vor mir. Ich habe nicht diese, ich sitze mit Laptop auf den Oberschenkelphase, habe ich nicht. Nee, die habe ich manchmal. Immer direkt auf dem Bauch. Aber spannend, wie lang, also meine Einschlafphase, wenn man die dann schon betreibt, ist ungefähr zwei Stunden lang. Also wie diese Laptop, ich werde langsam in Richtung immer vertikaler gemacht. Das ist schon lang eigentlich. In Zeitlupe fällst du einfach um, also in Zeitraffer einfach so. In Zeitraffer stehe ich die meiste Zeit, dann sitze ich irgendwann, dann beginne ich schon zu liegen, dann liege ich richtig und der Kopf fällt so langsam weg. Ja, ich bade ja in letzter Zeit sehr viel. Ich habe jetzt eine Wohnung mit einer Badewanne, das heißt, ich gehe oft nochmal in die Badewanne. Ja, wohnt jetzt in der Badephase, ich weiß nicht, was... Ey, total Badephase, ich glaube, mein Körper ist so weich, ich glaube, du könntest mit deiner Hand wirklich durch meinen Körper in meine Organe greifen, weil mein Körper ist komplett aufgelöst. Ich bin schwamm, wirklich, alles ist so, ich bin wie deine Kellogg's Tresor. Die gerade rumstehen und widerlich voller Milch sind. Die zu lange in der Milch sind und sich komplett auflösen. Du kannst es aber irgendwann auch nicht mehr machen. Irgendwann ist die Grenze übererschritten. Tresor saugt dich so voll. Mittlerweile habe ich so wenigstens fünf Zentimeter große Schwämme hier drin. Aber Kellogg's Tresor ist schon geil. Schon supergut, ja. Schon geil. Aber tatsächlich mein Körper, du kannst komplett durch mich durchlaufen. Ich habe manchmal das Gefühl... Du bist auch so gläsern mittlerweile, so ein Fisch, so gläsernlich. Total. Und ich liebe es und ich liege in einer heißen Badewanne und es ist heiß und ich höre Musik dabei und es ist toll. Und ich drehe mich hin und her. Ich habe mir gekauft. Stockdunkel. Das sind so ein Bambustischchen, was du in die Badewanne stellen kannst.
In die Badewanne?
Ja, auf die Badewanne und rauf.
Oder auf die Ränder.
Auf die Ränder, ja, ja, ja.
Und dann kannst du quasi liegen und oben drauf den Laptop stellen.
Schön ein Wein, ein Bierglas, ein Cola, je nachdem, für wen, allen ist das dabei.
Schön kannst du dann deinen Laptop draufstellen und was gucken.
Und hinten ein Badewannenkissen.
Badewannenkissen!
Ja, oh, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Doch!
Nee, nee, das spannt den Nacken zu sehr an.
Dadurch wird der Nacken zu sehr vorgedrückt.
Das ist die Möglichkeit, die die den Nacken zu sehr an. Dadurch wird der Nacken zu sehr vorgedrückt. Du musst den Nacken schon ein bisschen Rückenladen. Aber das ist doch das grösste Problem von Badewannen. Die Ränder, wo du dich anlehnt. Bei mir passt ganz gut. Der Körper muss sich auf der Badewanne anpassen, nicht andersrum. Aber Laptop würde mich irritieren, weil dann musste ja irgendwie mal Helligkeit runter oder Lautstärke und dann musst du halt immer mit deinen nassen Händen drauf rumdotzen.
Deswegen habe ich meine Hände immer ausgestreckt auf dem Wasser. Jazzhands auch die ganze Zeit. Was aber auch doof ist, und das ist für mich die größte Schwäche, die Smartphones momentan noch haben. Smartphones, glaube ich, kann man sagen, ist eine Erfindung, die sich langsam der Vollendung neigt. Bald ist durch. Genauso wie Treppen. Viel kann man da nicht mehr machen, wir haben eine Rolltreppe. Passt, ist halt durch. So, und jetzt, Smartphone ist für mich auch bald am Ende das einzige.
Es gibt jetzt viele wasserdichte Smartphones, die sich gut für, passt, ist halt durch. So, und jetzt, Smartphone ist für mich auch bald am Ende das einzige,
es gibt jetzt viele wasserdichte Smartphones, die sich gut für die Badewanne eignen, aber
die Touchscreen-Funktion
leidet immer noch stark.
Unter Wasser, und vor allem
die nasse Hände hast, geht da gar nichts mehr.
Wenn du dann deinen Fingerabdruckst,
das geht gar nicht mehr. Wenn der Finger gerüppelt ist,
oder was? Ja, wenn der Finger gerüppelt ist, genau,
richtig nervig, oh, und wenn er nass ist, funktioniert es auch nicht. Aber tatsächlich... Und bei vielen Schwarzen funktioniert es nicht. Was auch noch ein Problem ist, da muss Apple auch noch machen. Damit hat Apple nicht gerechnet, das Schwarze, das Wurzeln. Damit hätte man nicht rechnen können. Aber das ist tatsächlich ein Problem, du kannst dein Touchscreen nicht mehr benutzen, wenn deine Hände nass sind. Und dann musst du immer die Touchscreen trocken machen, deine Hände trocken machen, das ist nervig. Da will ich noch, wenn Samsung jetzt rauskommen würde, mit ihrem Samsung 11 und sagen würde, Leute, Badewanne ist kein Problem mehr, ihr könnt auch mit nassen Fingern den Touchscreen bedienen, würde ich sagen, da steige ich auf Samsung um. Das ist für mich ein Grund, wo ich sage, da würde ich umsteigen. Das ist aber auch ein iPhone 2, also von daher hast du auch keine Anforderungen wirklich. Das ist schon spannend, da ist auf jeden Fall noch viel möglich. Auch so Unterwasser gucken, dieses ganze Business mit, das ist auch noch nicht.
Unterwasser-Lautsprecher sind auch noch ganz toll, habe ich auch welche gefunden, aber das Problem ist, du hast ja dann so einen toastergrossen Kasten in deiner Badewanne, der ist rumschwimmen. Ja, und da ist auch Strom drin, denkst du auch so, bei allem, bei sowas bin ich auch, aber wenn jetzt ein Laptop ins Wasser fällt, was ist denn tot? Ich finde, Föhn in Badewanne, als ich dachte, dass das tödlich ist, war das ein Riesen-Moment.
Wenn mich ein Föhn, ein F Föhn in Badewanne, also ich glaube, dass das tödlich ist, war das ein Riesen-Moment.
Wenn mich ein Föhn, ein Föhn in der Badewanne umbringt, was bringt mich noch alles um? Ja, aber Föhn braucht richtig viel Strom. Alles, was erhitzt, braucht richtig viel Strom. Aber Moment mal, aber ich stelle mir vor, wenn das, was ist denn, was fällt in Badewanne und du bist tot? Und ist da wirklich der Übergang wirklich null oder eins? Du überlebst, Föhn, du stirbst, Laptop, du lebst, oder gibt es da so einen fliessenden Übergang, zwischendurch auch so ein Koma, zwölf Monate? Naja, ein Laptop ist ja nicht direkt an eine Steckdose angeschlossen. Ich glaube, wenn du Föhn reinfällst, dann hast du eine direkte Verbindung von Steckdose zu Wasser. Ich glaube, ohnehin würde eh einfach die Sicherung rausspringen und dir würde nicht so viel passieren,
glaube ich, aber ich bin mir nicht hundertprozentig sicher.
Aber Strom ist doch schnell. Ist die Sicherung schneller als der Strom?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich weiß nicht genau. Ich glaube, mittlerweile
gibt es da bestimmte Möglichkeiten, dass das nicht mehr so krass ist.
Entweder hat der Föhn irgendwas eingebaut,
dass der sagt Stopp, oder dass die
Sicherung Stopp sagt. Ich glaube, das ist nicht mehr so einfach. Aber ich glaube,
generell ist ein Föhn
schwieriger als ein Laptop. Aber auch ich vertraue natürlich dem Hersteller von diesen Unterwasserboxen, dass die natürlich daran denken, dass man nicht unter Strom gesetzt wird.
Aber trotzdem.
oder Brimbo-Lautsprecher unter Wasser, die auch nicht Amazon selber liefert, sondern die irgendwie so eine japanische Firma nebenbei immer so liefert, die aber auch Prime anbieten, komischerweise.
Also, bei mir ist es immer so, bei solchen Sicherheits, ich gebe den Herstellern immer einen. Ich gebe ihn einen. Und zwar mein Vater hat früher immer gesagt, das ist doch das Erste, woran die denken. Und das ist eine Argumentation, in der ich folge. So, das ist das Erste, woran die denken, ist, ich möchte nicht, dass mein Kunde komplett stirbt, wenn er das Produkt benutzt. So, zum Beispiel habe ich auch manchmal das Gefühl, wenn ich in einem Bus sitze
und mich an die Fensterscheibe anlehne,
eine grosse Glasscheibe,
und dann fährt der Bus manchmal in eine scharfe
Kurve und ich werde gegen die Fensterscheibe
gedrückt. Und dann denke ich mir auch,
wie viel hält diese Fensterscheibe aus,
bricht die? Und dann denke ich, habe ich immer die Stimme des Vaters
im Kopf, das ist doch das Erste,
woran der Bauer dieser Scheibe denkt,
dass sie nicht kaputt ist. Und dann sage ich,
dann bin ich befriedigt und sage, gut,
Das ist ein sehr guter Punkt. Bricht die. Und dann denke ich, habe ich immer die Stimme meines Vaters im Kopf, das ist doch das Erste, woran der Bauer dieser Scheibe denkt, dass sie nicht kaputt ist. Ja, Beispiel. Und dann bin ich befriedigt und sage, gut, das passt. Ich war mal in einer Kirmes und dann war da so ein, wie beschreibe ich das, so eine große, wie so eine Strafbank vom Eishockey, sagen wir mal, wo man sich, also wirklich einfach eine Reihe von Sitzen, wo man sich sitzen konnte und dann fährt die halt so im Uhrzeigersinnigersinn wird die halt so hochgedreht, für Kinder. Dann war es da drin, dann kam es da Bogen und dann fing das so an. Und ich habe gemerkt, oh, okay, ist ganz schön locker so, alles klar. Naja, dann dachte ich mir, ja, das ist ja das Erste, woran die denken, dass man hier nicht drin stirbt. Und plötzlich ging der Bügel immer weiter hoch und immer ein bisschen weiter hoch. Und ich wurde immer ein bisschen weitergeschlägt. Plötzlich saß ich auf einem anderen Sitz und dann war diese Begrenzung schon weg. Und dann war ich plötzlich woanders und dachte mir, okay, alles klar. Und dann habe ich auch gerufen. Ich bin mir sicher, das ist das Erste, woran ihr denkt, dass man hier nicht stirbt. Dennoch möchte ich meine Beschwerden hier mal kurz. Trotzdem, ganz kurz, unangenehm, es ist unangenehm, die haben das Ding angehalten, gut, TÜV hat das nicht entdeckt irgendwie, war ein Fehler drin. Und ich denke, ja, fickt euch einfach. Es sterben ja auch Menschen bei sowas. Aber kannst du denn jetzt noch Achterbahn gehen und so, oder hast du Vertrauen komplett verloren? Nö, Lebenslust verloren. Von daher alles gut. Nee, passt schon. Ich habe nur Vertrauen drin. Ich denke mir, es ist mir einmal passiert, es wird mir schon nicht ins Leiters mal passieren. Ah, der Lotto-Effekt. Dove Logik, ich weiß, macht aber keinen Sinn, aber psychisch hat man das schon. Ja, ja, okay. Ich glaube, wenn mir sowas mal passieren würde, ich weiß nicht, ob ich da ein komplettes Vertrauen verlieren würde. Bist du ängstlich? Ich glaube, wenn ich einen Grund habe, ängstlich zu sein, dann bin ich richtig ängstlich. Bist du so ein, ich entscheide zwischen körperlich verängstigter Menschen und die, die es nicht haben. Nämlich im Fußballverein war ich immer der, wenn jemand doll ausgeholt hat und geschossen hat, ich habe mich immer, egal wo der hinschießt, immer weggedreht, tendenziell eher vom Ball weg. Es gibt Leute, die ihren Körper aktiv schützen wollen und die, die ihren Körper aktiv in Gefahr bringen wollen. Und ich war immer der Erste, immer der, der sich wegdreht, immer der, wo alle sagen, oh, da ist Angst vor dem Ball. Ja, weil der Ball auch manchmal schnell ist und dann auch schnell dir ins Gesicht fliegt. Ja, das doch dann eher schon. Da war ich auch mal skeptisch bei Ball. Aber ich habe auch lange Handball gespielt, war auch im Tor lange bei Handball, im Kinderalter, da hatte ich keine Angst. Aber sobald dann irgendwie wirklich die Leute durch die Pubertät sind und wirklich plötzlich richtig kräftig sind und so eine fucking E-Jugend dann auch mal richtig draufballert, ist es mir zu viel. E-Jugend ist mir zu krass. E-Jugend war krass, oder? Da wurden die Tore auch schon größer und dann findet es auch ein krass. Alter, wow. Da wurden die richtig gross. Als man plötzlich nur noch mit Jungs im Team war und nicht mehr bei den Minis mit den Mädchen, da war es Serious Business. Pampers-Liga hieß es bei uns. Ja, bei uns waren es die Minis. Wo du auch dich nicht ernst genommen fühlst als professioneller Spieler in der Pampers-Liga. Du kannst mit sechs schon professioneller Spieler sein, aber du bist halt ein junger Spieler. Du bist halt in der Pampers-Liga. Aber der Beste in der Pampers-Liga. Auch Pro-Placement kann es sein, oder? Vielleicht war das einfach Pro-Placement, aber man wusste gar nicht. Ja, stimmt. Wobei mittlerweile, ich weiß nicht, ob man bei sowas nicht unterscheidet, schon zwischen Tempo-Taschentuch. Klügelter Name, Tempo-Taschentuch, ja. Warum sagt man Tempo-Taschentuch? Guck mal,? Taschentuch. Tempo sagt man einfach. Gib mir ein Tempo. Hast du ein Tempo? Ich habe ein Tempo tatsächlich. Hast du auch zwei Tempo? Mach mal Tempo. Ich habe tatsächlich immer Taschentüren dabei. Die sind immer so warm. Aber die riechen sehr stark nach dir und sind sehr warm. Aber unterscheidest du denn zwischen Gesäßwärme und anderer Wärme? Weil ich habe die in der Gesäßtasche. Ja, merkt man. Und auch diesen Gesäßtaschengeruch, der nicht per se schlecht ist, er ist einfach sehr intensiv mit dem Körpergeruch.
Also vor allem, du hast ja auch bei nichts anderem, presst du was, was gerade an dem Gesäß deines Kompagnons war, in dein Gesicht, das kommt ja selten vor.
Ich glaube, nie war mein Gesäß und dein Gesicht so nah beieinander, wie wenn du und Taschen ... Wir hatten schon unsere Momente. Aber bei ... aber tatsächlich bei ... habe ich das noch nicht erlebt, da habe ich ... du presst einfach so den ganzen Körpergeruch des Gegenübers und Gesässwärme in dein Gesicht und dann wirst du und dann schnüpfst du da rein. Das ist schon unangenehm. Aber wo soll man Taschentuch sonst tragen? Ich meine, in der Vordertasche hast du dann halt eher die Schrittwärme. Ich weiß nicht, ob die besser ist. Aber ich habe die Erfahrung gemacht, Achtung, Lebensregel, das nächste Taschentuch ist nicht weit. Weil nicht nur Taschentücher sind Taschentücher, sondern auch Servierten, Papiertücher, oder sonst, Klopapier, alles kann als Taschentuch dienen, potenziell. Papier, hast du schon mal Papier benutzt? Warst du schon mal so verzweifelt? Oh ja, bitte, klar. Ja? Ich habe schon mal iPads benutzt. Wirklich, also ich habe eine sehr laufende Nase. Socke? Ja, klar, Socke. Dieses Masturbation in Socke, ist das ein Ding eigentlich jemals gewesen? Ich glaube, es ist ein amerikanisches Ding. Warum sollte man das tun? Es ist doch nichts, sag doch einer Mutter mehr, ich wichse mir einen runter, als eine volle Socke. Ja, ich weiss es nicht, keine Ahnung, wo das herkommt. Das ist vielleicht ... Ist doch doof einfach. Vielleicht ist es auch ein Komfortding, dass es weich ist oder so, und es hat ja auch so ein bisschen so einen Vaginalcharakter oder so, vielleicht was anderes als ein Taschentuch, was jetzt nicht so ... Nicht so geil ist, meinst du. Weiss ich nicht genau. Weiss ich nicht, keine Ahnung. Müssten wir mal Leute interviewen, die das mit Socken machen? Ich bis jetzt noch nicht. Ja, schreibt mal. Schreibt mal an socke-podcast-ufo.fail Eine Adresse, die wir für einen anderen Zweck angelegt hatten, aber gut. Ist leider nichts geworden aus unserem Start-up. Drei Socken, weil eine verliert man ja immer, deswegen kauft man drei Socken auf einmal. Nein, will niemand, will niemand, will gar niemand, wenn ihr zwei Pakete kauft, habt ihr zumindest auch eine gerade Zahl. Keine Hand ist oben, keine einzige Hand ist oben. Was ist das für ein Zeichen, sollen wir gehen? Was ist das für ein Zeichen? Oh Mann, ey, schade. Oh Mann. Wir haben schon so oft unser ganzes Patreon-Geld investiert in Start-Up, das hat immer nicht funktioniert. Was, ja, weiss, kurze Frage, wie viel, also, wie teuer ist eine Maschine, die Mentos herstellt? 60.000 Euro. 60.000 Euro? Nee. Wann haben die das wieder rein? Die ganze Fabrik, 600.000 Euro. 600.000, eine Maschine für eine Sorte Mentos, wann haben die das wieder rein, wenn die wie viel Mentos verkauft haben? Weil, ich frage aus diesem einen Grund, ich habe es schon ein paar Mal angesprochen, es ist mir wirklich unglaublich wichtig. Ich vermisse das manchmal, ich habe manchmal am Wochenende auch so Flashbacks an diese bessere Zeit. Mentos Energy ist der perfekte Wachmachwebe zwischendurch. Wonach schmeckt das? Es schmeckt ein bisschen nach Red Bull, ein bisschen nach diesem typischen Mentos-Eigengeschmack, den es ja auch hat, den man ja nicht abstreiten kann. Und so ein bisschen was dazwischen, so ein bisschen süsslicher. Es hat so verschiedene Phasen, so verschiedene Lutschphasen. Es geht so langsam von Mentos zu Red Bull zu süss. Ganz, ganz toll einfach. Um ganz ehrlich zu sein, ich habe nie verstanden, wie man Mentos essen soll. Deswegen jetzt mal an dich die Frage, professionelle Mentosexperte, wie isst man ein Mentos? Es kommt ein bisschen auf die Sorte an. Also je fruchtiger, desto länger will man sie im Mund haben. Lutschen, kauen, Zwischendingen. Du nimmst ja auch nicht einen und dann ist das immer gut, wie ein Fisherman's Friends. Du nimmst erst mal einen Fisherman's Friends und dann ist es gut. Die FF-Sättigung ist relativ schnell erreicht, die M-Sättigung, Mentors-Sättigung, ist nicht so schnell erreicht. Du isst ja ein paar Mal mehr nacheinander. Meiner Erfahrung nach, den ersten, da bist du gierig, kaust du schnell drauf. Willst schön erstmal maximal viel Geschmack drin haben. Aber von Anfang an kauen oder erstmal aufweichen? Kurz aufweichen, kauen, dann direkt kauen. Also schon, wir werden wenig weichen, dann kauen. Und beim zweiten Mal, es wird dann immer, die Kauphasen werden immer geringer oder dauern immer, bis sie einsetzen dann. Und du lutscht immer mehr. Die Lutschphase nehmen zu. Und wie viel Prozent der Mentors-Packung isst du so pro Sitzung? Ich würde sagen, die ganze Packung. Schon die ganze, für Wacke-Snack. Und tatsächlich war das auch, glaube ich, ein Grund, warum Mentors Energy eingestellt wurde, weil es gefährlich ist. Eine Rolle sind zwei Tassen Kaffee und zwei starke Tassen Kaffee. Es ist halt Koffein in Süssigkeiten generell, ist was ganz breitens. Das sieht man auch gar nicht mehr häufig. Stimmt, es kann sein, dass es einfach generell verboten wurde. Nee, wurde es nicht. Ich habe schon vor ein paar Jahren mal eine Mail an Mentos geschrieben. Es wurde eingestellt, weil es nicht gekauft wurde. Aber meine ganzen Mentos Energy Foren im Internet, die quillen ja über vor Leuten. Es sind Milliarden Leute, die Mentos Energy wieder zurück wollen. Es wurde auch in anderen Ländern nicht eingestellt. Kannst du das Internet bestellen, wenn es in anderen Ländern noch produziert wird? Es wurde auch eingestellt. Tatsächlich heißt das ja, dass es nicht an Länderregeln, so Koffein, Düssigkeiten wie Überraschungsei, was ja in Amerika verboten ist. So regionale Sachen sind was, das wurde nicht gekauft einfach. Was ich nicht verstehen kann, weil wenn du kurz wach sein willst und du willst dann nicht nochmal einen Kaffee trinken, deinen dritten oder so, dann holst du dir einfach schön Mentos Energy, ballast dir da rein und es ist lecker, es macht extrem wach zwischendurch, das ist so gut. Ich habe noch nie Koffein bewusst eingesetzt, um wacher zu sein. Ich trinke gerne Mate, ich trinke gerne schwarzen Tee, ich trinke gerne Cola. Aber für mich ist Koffein eigentlich immer nur ein störender Nebeneffekt, dass ich nachts nicht schlafen kann. Ich habe noch nie gesagt, jetzt muss ich wach sein, jetzt trinke ich Cola. Doch. Schöner hoch nach dem aufregenden Mittagessen, dass man nochmal einen Hoch bekommt. Was ist ein aufregendes Mittagessen für dich? Aufregendes Mittagessen ist Burger mit zwei Patties, schön süssere Toffelpommes. Mit zwei? Oh, das ist aufregend. Das ist dann schon, der Magen ist dann ein bisschen unruhig und dann fällt man in so ein leichtes Mittagstief. Und da braucht man schon mal, da will man auch keinen Kaffee mehr. Da trinkt man dann schwarzen Tee oder sowas, auch eher was für Abend, deswegen weiß ich nicht. Die Mate, ja. Schon die Mate dann, ja. Ich brauche das schon, ich setze da aktiv für Eingegenmütigkeit,, morgens auch gerne. Aber Mentos Energy ist wirklich der perfekte Wachbacher zwischendurch. Und ich möchte Mentos fragen, arbeitet irgendwer bei euch bei Mentos oder kennt jemanden, der da arbeitet? Ich will einfach gerne herausfinden, wie teuer, weil Petitionen und so starten, okay, bringt alles nichts. Ich glaube einfach, ich hätte gerne eine Charge. Ich würde gerne einfach selber diesen Einstieg in den Mentors Energy-Markt wieder erleichtern, indem ich einfach so ein Startkapital gebe. Und ich will wissen, wie teuer ist das, so eine Produktmarke neu einzuführen wieder, weil die Rezeptur habt ihr noch rumfliegen in eurer Akten. Wollen wir mal ein bisschen ein paar Geheimnisse lüften aus guter Arbeit Originals? Wir hatten nämlich mal ganz zu Anfang des Projekts, als wir noch diese Fake-Trailer gemacht haben, um ein bisschen aufmerksam zu haben. Das war eine ganz strange Phase. Rückwirkend ist eine mega strange Phase. Ich habe kaum Erinnerungen an diese Phase. Und das war eine Phase, wo wir Werbung gemacht haben für den Indie-Trailer und für die Morning-Show, was alles Fake war und eigentlich war noch eine dritte Werbung geplant. Ja, denn die kennt uns. Eigentlich ist die Comedy 3 natürlich das Ziel. Die Comedy 3. Eigentlich war noch eine dritte Werbung geplant, und zwar für den Gute-Arbeit-Schukuriegel.
Und das sollte ein Riegel sein, ein Schukuriegel mit einem Kern aus Fruchtgummi.
Und da gab es Diskussionen.
Ich habe so einen 2 zu 3-Machstab aufgemalt, wir haben schon die Verpackung designt und so weiter.
Total.
Wir haben auch eine Firma gefunden, die das sogar gemacht hätte. Genau, es sollte eine Fake-Werbung sein, wir wollten aber, dass es diese Regel tatsächlich gibt. Und dass wir die tatsächlich auch verteilen können und vielleicht nicht verkaufen, aber dürfen wir nicht, wir sind öffentlich-rechtlich, aber verteilen. Und wenn jemand reinschickt, dann hat er das bekommen oder sowas. Und das wäre mega geil gewesen. Wir hatten Kontakt mit Haribo und unsere Redakteurin hat auch Haribo angeschrieben, die dann sowas war, ja, die würden das per se schon umsetzen, aber die hätten halt eine Mindestmenge von 60 Tonnen. Stimmt, 60 Tonnen! 60 Tonnen! Ist das Mindeste, was Haribo produzieren muss, sonst lohnt es sich für die wahrscheinlich gar nicht, ihre Fabrik anzuwerfen. 60 Tonnen! Hätten wir denn gehabt, und es kostet halt dann keine Ahnung, eine Million Euro oder sowas, so viel Fruchgummi zu haben. Aber das wäre potenziell möglich gewesen. Also wir waren aber auch... Wir waren eine Mail und eine Überweisung entfernt, einen eigenen Riegel zu haben. Das ist schon sehr einfach. Wie viele Riegel sind das? Zwei oder zwei grosse? Wenn der 100 Gramm sind, dann sind das 10.000, 60.000 Riegel dann. 60.000 Riegel, oder? Ja, macht schon Sinn. Auf jeden Fall spannende Sache und ich möchte auf jeden Fall euch bitten. Nee, 600.000. Hast du gesagt, lest euch ein in das Mentors Energy Business, holt mal Infos rein und dann starten wir zusammen neu Mentors Energy. Ja es ja ungefähr 60 Tonnen Mentos Energy müssen die mindestens herstellen. Ja, aber das kriegt man doch weg. Das Interesse im Internet ist ja da. Also wir müssen halt irgendwie die Verbindung herbekommen. Ich komme halt nur über diese Service Hotline, wo man mich mittlerweile schon wegdrückt, wenn man meine Nummer blockiert hat. Und halt die Mails, wo man dann im Service Center landet, wo die sagen, naja, wir möchten stattdessen Mentos Fruit empfehlen, wo ich auch teilweise schon patzig zurückgeschrieben habe, das ist aber nicht das Gleiche. Wie jemand, der seit Jahren abhängig ist von Mentos. Das ist nicht das Gleiche, okay? Und auch Tropical Fruit ist auch nicht dasselbe wie Fruit, okay? Ich weiß. Ich kenne die neuen Sorten, okay? Naja, und das würde ich halt einfach wahnsinnig gerne zurückbringen. Also das vermisse ich wirklich sehr. Ja, ich habe Mentos Energy nie probiert, muss aber sagen, dass ich momentan sehr zufrieden bin mit der Mentos Lakritz und Minz. Ja, aber das genau ... Lakritz-Minz ist eine geile Kombination. Leute wie du sind scheiße für mein Vorhaben. Ey, Lakritz-Minz. Weil je mehr du neue Sorten von Mentos unterstützt, desto mehr habe ich keine Chance, meine alten zurückzubekommen. Ich bin der Opotenist an der Stelle, ich nutze deine Notlage aus, um noch mehr Lakritz-Mintz-Mentos für mich rauszuschlagen. Ja, vielleicht werden wir ab der nächsten Folge gesponsert von Mentos mal gucken, dann könnten wir das ja vielleicht verwenden. Und wenn wir genug Interessenten hätten, start doch mal eine Petition. Die haben auch keinen deutschen Twitter-Account so richtig. Ich würde einfach mal gerne wissen, ich habe den englischen Ausschnitt auch schon angeschrieben, keine Antwort. Ich möchte einfach gerne wissen, wie viel Geld wollt ihr haben, dass ich
mal einfach die Maschinen
anwerfe für eine neue
Charge Mentors Energy. Weil das Rezept
wird doch rumfliegen. Ihr müsst doch nur, und
ihr habt doch nicht verschiedene Maschinen
für verschiedene Sorten. Da ist doch nicht irgendwie
plötzlich so ein Urwald
Fruit Tropical
Ding, Tropical Fruit
Mentors. Da ist doch kein, da fliegt so nicht wie ein Tukan rum und die Halle ist ein Wald. Nein! Ihr habt einfach zwei große, metallene Maschinen, die diese Mentors herstellen. Dann baut da mal eine, stellt die mal um für einen Tag auf Mentors Energy. Echt spannend, diese Produktherstellung. Aber deren Maschinen laufen doch 24,7, oder? Das heißt, wenn die jetzt... Ich glaube, die laufen 24-7, 356-12. Aber ich meine, wenn die jetzt seine 60 Tonnen produzieren, fehlen denen ja 60 Tonnen Mentos Fruit. Und dann müssen die ihre ganze Logistik umdenken, weil die müssen ja auch liefern, oder nicht? Das ist doch nicht so leicht. Das macht nicht so viel aus. Ich weiß nicht. Aber die werden ja nicht stillstehen. Da liegt aber auch so viel rum. Also überall liegen doch Mentors rum. Siehst du, überall liegen doch Mentors rum. Da fällt doch nicht auf, wenn er mal zwei Rollen jener Kiosk wählt. Ich will nicht, dass am Ende unserer Podcast dafür verantwortlich ist, dass in Deutschland Mentorsknappheit herrscht und ein Kiosk irgendwie nicht mehr mit Mentors geliefert werden kann. Lieber Ment, lieber Mentors-Knappheit als Mentors-Energy-Knappheit. Wow.
Ich weiß nicht, ob dieses Projekt abhebt,
ob dieses Mentors-Energy-Bedürfnis so da ist.
Aber ich weiss, was abhebt.
Nämlich das Podcast-UFO. Bis zum
nächsten Wochen. Wenn wir deswegen jetzt
zehn Minuten eher Schluss machen, dann würde ich über deine
Heim einhauen. Macht's gut, wir freuen uns,
bis zum nächsten Mal, wir heben ab.
Wir haben die noch nicht begrüßt.